foreign
welcome to another installment of Harry
Potter Theory today we'll be discussing
a chronological timeline of events that
transpired after the defeat of Lord
Voldemort as the final pages of the
Harry Potter series Drew to a close in
the last credits rolled in the movie
adaptations fans of the magical world
were left with a sense of Bittersweet
satisfaction the defeat of Lord
Voldemort marked the end of an era
filled with danger heroism and
surprising twists however it also marked
the beginning of an Uncharted chapter in
Wizarding World History the fall of
Voldemort brought about a newfound
freedom and a chance for healing it
signaled an opportunity for The
Wizarding Community to rebuild and
address the lingering scars of a war
that had deeply impacted their lives
today we'll explore these significant
events that unfolded in the greater
Wizarding World after the climactic
battle of Hogwarts and the conclusion of
the series navigating a detailed
timeline that spans years revealing the
triumphs and challenges that shamed this
transitional period before we begin
though please note that this video will
focus on a general timeline of events
for more detail on what happened to each
character watch my video what happened
to these 100 Harry Potter characters
after the war and for more detail on how
the Wizarding World rebuilt itself watch
my video A New Beginning what happened
to The Wizarding World after Voldemort's
defeat this video will focus on larger
events rather than dive too much into
the minutia from the moments the dust
settled on the Hogwarts grounds to the
years that followed we will unravel the
threads of Wizarding World History
witnessing how The World of Magic
pressed forward before we jump in though
please consider giving the video like as
it helps the channel grow let's dive
into it 1998 whenever McGonagall
reprizes her role and becomes full-time
headmistress of Hogwarts School she
focused on rebuilding the school
restoring its Prestige and ensuring the
safety of students McGonagall work
tirelessly to restore the curriculum
nurturing new generations of young
witches and wizards her leadership was
marked by her unwavering dedication to
academic excellence and unwavering
commitment to protecting student welfare
under her Guidance the school flourished
and regained its esteemed status in the
magical Community
mcgonagall's tenures headmistress
reflected her resilience wisdom and
unwavering loyalty to Hogwarts and its
students Hogwarts is rebuilt after
Voldemort's defeat Hogwarts underwent
extensive reconstruction to restore its
once Splendid halls with the combined
effort of dedicated Wizards and the
support of The Wizarding Community this
restoration project revived Hogwarts as
the prestigious School of magic it once
was ready to welcome new generations of
students in Kingsley shackle bolt
becomes temporary Minister for magic
immediately after the defeat of
Voldemort in the Battle of Hogwarts
Kingsley shackle bolt was made caretaker
Minister for magic during this time
shacklebolt implemented policies that
aimed to rectify the injustices of the
previous regime promoting inclusivity
and equality his tenure as Minister saw
significant progress and laid the
foundation for a more united and
harmonious magical Society shacklebolt
has later made permanent Minister a
position he held for many years
1998 quidditch World Cup due to the
turmoil caused by the dark Mark's
appearance at the 1994 quidditch World
Camp the 1998 tournament saw significant
enhancements in security measures 1999
graduation among others Ginny Weasley
and Luna Lovegood graduate from Hogwarts
Hermione also graduates this year due to
her education being prolonged as a
result of her efforts towards the defeat
of followed Voldemort Harry and Ron do
not return and never graduate formally
Ministry Reformation occurs after the
devastating Wizarding War the ministry
of magic underwent a comprehensive
reform corrupt officials were removed
new policies were implemented to promote
equality and justice and efforts were
made to bridge the gap between magical
communities the goal was to rebuild
trust restore order and create a better
future for all witches and wizards 2000
Kingsley Jackal bolt removes the
Dementors from Azkaban in his role as
the newly appointed Minister for Magic
shacklebolt undertakes the perilous
mission of oustingly Dementors from
Azkaban the ancient and malevolent
prison these creatures had served as
guards for centuries providing the
ministry with a means of exerting
limited control shacklebolt replaces the
dementor Guardians with auras ensuring a
more formidable and just security
presence Kingsley would see two at the
Azkaban will no longer use the mentors
the use of Dementors was always a mark
of the underlying Corruption of the
ministry as Dumbledore constantly
maintained
Ron Weasley leaves the aura office after
Voldemort's defeat Ron Weasley becomes a
dark wizard catcher at the ministry of
magic along with Harry however his
career is short-lived as just two years
after starting the position he leaves to
join his brother George in running
Weasley's wizard wheezers
2002 quidditch World Cup and crumbs
retirement the Quidditch World Cup 2002
final match was played between Egypt and
Bulgaria after the Seeker raulya zaglul
caught the snitch Egypt ended up beating
Bulgaria 450 points to 300. at this
point Bulgarian Seeker Victor Crum
announced his retirement from
International quidditch however crumb's
name still seems to be mentioned in a
number of subsequent quidditch events in
the years that followed
2006 Greenwich World Cup 2006. the team
from Burkina Faso emerged victorious in
the Quidditch World Cup 2006 clinching a
resounding victory over France the score
of 300 to 220. 2007 Harry Potter becomes
head of the aura Department after his
heroic defeat of Voldemort in 1998 Harry
Potter the young age of 17 joined the
esteemed ranks of the auras to further
combat the dark Forces that threatened
The Wizarding World over the years he
demonstrated exceptional skill bravery
and dedication earning the respect of
his colleagues in recognition of his
remarkable achievements Harry was
appointed as the head of the department
in 2007. entrusted with leading and
shaping the future of the aura division
with his unparalleled knowledge of the
dark arts and unwavering commitment to
Justice Harry proved to be an invaluable
asset in the ongoing fight against evil
2009 dead Lupine son of nymphadora Tonks
and Remus Lupine starts his education at
Hogwarts the 87th Wizarding school's
potions Championship takes place
showcasing the incredible talent and
skill of young Wizards and witches in
the art of potion making
2010 Samuel G kohog president of makusa
gets involved in the Quidditch World
Camp when American quidditch fans kidnap
Hans the augury the mascot of the
Liechtenstein national team during the
lead up to the Quidditch World camp in
2014.
Greenwich World Cup 2010 This World Cup
final featured an exciting three day
long match between the Chinese National
side and a team from Moldova and was
eventually won by China in a public
statement Rutherford poke the
spokesperson for Saint mungo's Hospital
for Magical Melodies and injuries
addressed the issue of recurring faux
flu injuries and emphasized the
importance of using the real thing which
only costs two sickles per scoop he also
warned that he would refuse treatment to
any wizard coming in with a burned
backside due to such negligence
hogsmeade attack during the first
weekend trip of the 2010 to 2011 school
year for Hogwarts students a masked and
cloaked individual named Elliot Evers
carried out an attack in hogsmade this
incident occurred after the attractions
organized by Victor Gridley
2011 Hogwarts School of Witchcraft and
Wizardry organized a festive event
called the blooming party to commemorate
the blossoming of a memberless
mimbletonia plant cultivated by
Professor Neville Longbottom who teaches
herbology
2014 quidditch World Cup 2014 opening
ceremony the 2014 quidditch World Cup
Opening Ceremony received significant
attention in the article titled
disastrous opening ceremony leads to
questions about quidditch world cup
security published by the daily Prophet
the article discusses the riots and
Calamity that unfolded before the
official matches of the tournament began
it highlights the disagreements blame
shifting and explanations provided by
Argentinian officials commentators and
the teams involved in the unfortunate
incident a whole lot of quidditch
matches the 2014 quidditch World Cup
hosted countries from all over the world
who competed in all sorts of exciting
matches this particular World Cup is
well documented in Wizarding World law
the Quidditch World Cup 2014 witnessed
several matches and upsets Norway
triumphed over Ivory Coast with a
dominant score of 340-100 facing
attempts to jinx their Chaser Nigeria
defeated Fiji with a controversial
snitch capture securing a score of 400
to 160. Brazil narrowly defeated Haiti
with an illegal snitch capture resulting
in a score of 100 to 90. the USA emerged
Victorious over Jamaica although the
score was not mentioned due to the
Jamaican Keepers infected
sassafonsonbyte Liechtenstein won
against Chad with the final score of
470-330 while Bulgaria dominated New
Zealand with a score of 410 to 170.
finally in the Quidditch World Cup for
2014 final Bulgaria merged as a
Champions defeating Brazil
160-70 in an electrifying game the
launch of Rita Skeeter's book
Dumbledore's Army the dark side of the
demob is published the book written by
the often controversial journalist Rita
Skeeter explores a potentially darker
side of Dumbledore's Army a group formed
by students at Hogwarts School of
Witchcraft and Wizardry during the
second Wizarding War
national gobstones league in Birmingham
according to the daily prophets
correspondent Ginny Weasley in her
coverage of the final of the 2014
quidditch World Cup it was reported that
the national gobstones league was
scheduled to take place in Birmingham
the following week 2015 James series
Potter is sorted into Gryffindor at 11AM
the firstborn child of Harry Potter
Ginny Weasley boards the Hogwarts
Express at King's cross after a day of
travel James arrives at the school and
is taken across the lake by boat before
entering the Great Hall the Sorting
ceremony takes place and to the
disappointment of Teddy Lupine who is
the head boy and a Hufflepuff James ends
up being sorted into Gryffindor House
the London 5 disappear the London 5
refers to a series of mysterious
disappearances that occurred in London
the ministry of magic was baffled by
these events as they had never
encountered such a phenomenon before
what made these disappearances
particularly puzzling was a lack of
evidence and Witnesses it seemed that
someone possessed the ability to make
highly skilled auras vanish without
leaving any traces behind the gravity of
these incidents captured the attention
of the entire Wizarding World News of
the disappearances spread far and wide
leading to speculation and theories
about the identity and motives of the
perpetrator the fear and uncertainty
surrounding these inexplicable events
intensified as people question the
safety of even the most skilled members
of the magical community
2016 Teddy Lupine son of nymphadora and
Remus graduates from Hogwarts and the
88th Wizarding school's potions
Championship is held in 2017 the new
generation at King's cross as seen in
the Harry Potter epilogue a significant
event takes place as Harry Ginny Ron and
Hermione come together to accompany
their children to the Hogwarts Express
and bid farewell to the older ones as
they embark on another school year Draco
Malfoy is also there with his wife and
son this is quite a symbolic moment as
it ushers in the Next Generation
Ron Weasley gets a muggle driving
license by confronting the examiner of
the driving test
2018 the ministry of magic makes a
public announcement regarding the
establishment of the statute of secrecy
task force this announcement signifies
the official recognition and formation
of a specialized group dedicated to
upholding the statute of secrecy the
statute of secrecy is a fundamental
piece of magical law that governs the
concealment of The Wizarding World from
the non-magical community in 2019
Hermione Granger becomes minister of
magic Hermione Granger's appointment as
minister of magic signifies her
intelligence leadership and commitment
to equality and justice her influence
promises significant reforms
advancements and representation for The
Wizarding community
Lily Luna Potter starts her education at
Hogwarts and is sorted into Gryffindor
the Calamity occurs This calamity is
well quite calamitous everything that
anyone has ever feared revered or held
there in the Wizarding World people
things even memories have been stolen
and displaced tossed about across the
world we've got to return what is lost
and quickly the statute of secrecy is in
danger of being broken in 2020 the
British Ministry of magic received
several reports at the Forbidden Forest
had seen an uptick in hippogriff
poaching the 2021 a major breach of the
international statute of Wizarding
secrecy occurs when a muggle journalist
Witnesses a member of the SOS task force
immobilizing Pixies subsequently the
journalist publishes articles disclosing
information about magic
2022 James Sirius finishes his education
at Hogwarts School of Witchcraft and
Wizardry in 2023 to be determined and
that concludes the timeline of major
events after the Wizarding war ended if
I've missed something please let me know
down in the comment section below also
be sure to comment your video requests
until next time remember it does not do
to dwell on dreams and forget to live
[Music]
foreign